[Music]
next
our next speaker is carson sievert who's
a software engineer at our studio who
uh works with the shiny team and he's
going to be talking about
creating reproducible shiny apps with
shiny meta
cool thank you winston and yeah
[Applause]
thanks everyone for being here i'm
excited to show you another project
that joe and i have been working on this
year uh
shiny meta and i want to start off
sort of by first sharing that
it's pretty crazy for me to be up here
doing this talk and standing in front of
you as a r studio software engineer
because it seems like not that long ago
i was a grad student struggling with
learning r and um
really you know not having a ton of fun
with it and certainly didn't expect
to become a software engineer at any
point within the next
say 10 years and
[Music]
in my second year of grad school i
discovered like gigi plot 2
and things that became the tidy verse
and
right around that same time you know i
was becoming more productive with my
my r programming and i then discovered
this thing called shiny and it just kind
of blew me away like how magical it was
to
like take my analysis and uh with very
minimal changes
uh turn it into an interactive web app
um so that was really the point where i
sort of became sort of
like really into r really into
programming
and i was just sort of blown away at how
i could enable others to sort of tease
apart
the data that i was working with and
also
found it really useful for teaching when
i was a grad student as well
so this interactive power that shiny
brings to the table
is really really great but we should
acknowledge that whenever we make the
decision to use an interactive tool
for our work as data scientists as
statisticians
that decision to use an interactive tool
over
reproducible code is going to come at
the cost of reproducibility
so if we focus in on shiny really the
core problem here
is that in order to do its thing shiny
sort of depends
on the user events to sort of drive the
application logic
and this shiny runtime execution
that sort of determines like what our
code to execute
in response to you know what user events
and at least for a number of years we've
been able to mostly work around this
problem
uh in in focus of user events
uh through shiny bookmarking so this at
least allows us to
save the state of the application at any
point in time
and in theory be able to come back to
the state of the application
sort of assuming that you know the app
is there available
and allowing us to sort of restore the
state to the application
but especially if we're not like if we
don't have control over the application
if somebody else is hosting that for us
our bookmarking url that we go to to go
back to the state of our application if
that app is no longer available
um we're kind of out of luck so in that
sense we still
lack some sense of permanence that we
get from reproducible r code
and even if the app is working and we
can sort of replicate the user events
and get back to the state of the
application
we still sort of lack some sense of
transparency in the sense that
those outputs are still locked behind a
graphical user interface
and if even if i could get at the source
code behind the application sort of the
core r
domain logic that i might be interested
in verifying
is correct that's still sort of
intertwined with shinee's
runtime engine and it's sort of hard to
know exactly like what our code is being
executed
at any point in time
so the goal here is we sort of want to
enable you to eliminate that
shiny runtime dependency in some sense
where
we want to enable you to write shiny
apps that can generate
our code to essentially mimic the code
that it's executing
so that you can run that code without
shiny and
without having to like duplicate that
logic yourself
in in multiple places
so the project that we're working on to
help
you enable this feature is the shiny
meta r package
and this provides tools for you as the
shiny app developer
to capture the core essential domain
logic
that is powering your application and
exposing it
as code to users that they can run
outside of the shiny app
so to demonstrate how shiny meta works
we're gonna work through this real basic
shiny app example uh it just has a text
input box where i can type in a
our package name and as i type in
different packages i can get a new time
series
of the number of downloads for the past
year for that given our package
so the goal is to modify this shiny
application
and add an ability for this code
to update every time i enter a new
package and give me reproducible r
code back that i can copy and paste into
a new
fresh r session and essentially mimic
the execution of this shiny application
so here is the entire implementation
of that basic shiny app as with any
shiny app there's two main
components the ui object at the top is
for the user interface it just has the
text input for where i put the package
name
and then the plot outputs sort of
container for the time series plot
and then the server logic below that is
going to determine how to take that
input from the text input box and create
the ggplot time series for the plot
output
so we're going to zoom in on this server
functionality
and the first step with adding shiny
meta integration
is determine where in the logic of my
shiny app
is the core domain logic that i want to
provide to my user
and we're going to walk through these
three different steps here so let's
focus in on step one
this downloads reactive essentially
it's taking the current value of this
text input and it's referencing that as
input dollar package feeding that into
this crayon downloads function
to give me the previous uh like the
downloads for the last year for this
package
and then in the downloads rolling
reactive we take the return value
of the downloads reactive and if it's a
sensible value
we will use dplyr in this zoo package to
compute a weekly rolling average
mainly just for visualization purposes
and notice that i haven't highlighted
this particular part
of the reactive expression this part
is mainly just here to improve the
interactive experience
of the shiny app and doesn't really have
uh any sort of uh
you know domain context in in terms of
actually producing the plot output
this is assuming we have a valid our
package name
is not really necessary to be here
so we'll talk a little bit about that in
the next step
but in the last step here we'll just
take the return value
of the downloads rolling and feed that
into ggplot
so domain logic here identified in blue
then the next step is to use shiny
meta's
meta-reactive building blocks
and capture that domain logic that we've
highlighted in blue
and those shiny meta reactive building
blocks are highlighted in pink
so the downloads reactive has just
changed from reactive to meta-reactive
so meta-reactive will assume that the
entire expression
is domain logic that you want to export
to the user
but in this case of the downloads
rolling
where we have just part of the reactive
expression that we want to
capture as domain logic we use meta
reactive two
instead and then we can just target a
particular part of that reactive
expression
with this metaexpert function and just
tag that as the domain logic that we
want to export
and then finally for rendering functions
since these are a little bit different
in the sense that anybody
can implement their own rendering
function
we meta render is kind of like a
decorator function where it takes the
rendering function as the first argument
here it's render plot and then the
second argument is the reactive
expression
right so now we've in some sense
captured the domain logic with these
meta-reactive equivalents to shiny
reactive building blocks and the next
part is to
within sort of the domain logic identify
any reactive reads so
at the very top here i'm reading the
current
value of the text input
and then down below i'm reading the
return value
of the downloads reactive expression
and reading the return value of the
downloads rolling
reactive
so this part is probably going to be the
hardest part to see but
once we've identified the reactive reads
in blue
then we're going to mark those reactive
reads with a dot dot
operator and this is going to
essentially provide a signal to the
shiny meta
code generation mode
and let it know that when we go to
generate code
from these reactive components
i want to essentially let shiny meta
know that these should be replaced with
either a static value that it represents
or a variable name that will represent
the value that it really represents so
we'll see that in a second
i also want to point out that this dot
dot operator you can think of it in some
sense uh
as the like the bang bang from arlang
in the sense that you can use it like a
unquoting operator
where if you wrap any sort of r
code that's not reactive it will just
evaluate that code instead of returning
the expression
so we'll see how this can be used to
essentially like hard code
a dynamic value
and then really the last step to
actually generating the code to mimic um
the code that the shiny app is actually
executing when it goes to
like fill in the outputs of the shiny
app
is to use this expand chain function and
here
i'm just providing it the plot outputs
object
but if you had multiple objects you
could provide multiple
outputs to this function and not only
will it return the domain logic
in a way that can run outside of the
shiny app
but uh it will also figure out sort of
the minimal amount of code necessary to
do so
so when we actually call expand chain it
it will return
all of the logic that we've captured
with with the meta-reactive building
blocks
and before returning it's going to walk
through this code and it's going to look
for these dot dot operators
and it's going to find this verts dot
dot operator and it's going to kind of
recognize that it's a marked input value
and in this case since this is just a
well what it will do is return it with
the current value that's in the text
input box
when we go and actually call this expand
chain function
all right and then this part there's
nothing really special in a reactive
sense about this r code inside this
dot dot operator but i'm essentially
just putting
the date as it stands today the day that
i'm generating this code
in a human readable format so this dot
dot operator can in some sense
be used to not only like hard code a
dynamic value
but also if you kind of master meta
programming in some sense if you're
familiar with
bang bang from arling you can use it in
ways to make your code that you're
generating a little more human readable
all right so now it's going to go to the
next dot dot operator and it's going to
recognize
oh this downloads reactive read this
actually represents a value
that now actually exists in this code
that i'm generating
because it's going to recognize that you
know the downloads reactive that we now
have static code for
this is a variable that now exists so i
can just simply replace
this reactive read with the variable
name
and then it'll do the same thing for the
downloads rolling
now that we're essentially creating a
new variable downloads rolling
i can reuse that in the ggplot
uh visualization call
all right so for most serious
applications your reactive code is going
to rely on some setup code
uh sort of like some subset maybe of the
setup code that
you know you have above your your
launching of the shiny app
to do things like loading libraries and
reading and data these sort of things
and at least one way that you can
approach this today
is you can quote that subset of code and
provide it to expand chain and it'll
just return it verbatim
and that's all we really need to get
this application
uh spitting out our code that i can then
copy
and paste in a fresh r session to mimic
the code that the reactives are actually
executing
but i don't actually recommend just
inlining code like this in your shiny
app
we should really think about providing a
better user experience
there's a couple ways to do this with
shiny meta but i'm going to show you the
more powerful approach
which is to have something like a
download button
and have this button call this build rmd
bundle from shiny meta
which allows you to provide a zip bundle
to your user
with both like an rmd source file with
the code that's influenced by the user
input
as well as the rendered output of that
our markdown source
so if we start with our expand chain
that's generating the code to mimic
the code that we need for the
time series visualization we can slip
that inside
a download handler and take the result
of that expand chain call and feed it
into this build rmd bundle
but this build rmd bundle will also need
in our markdown template
and here is where you can specify where
in your arm
markdown template you actually want to
place the code
so and this could be pretty useful when
you have
say lots lots of different outputs in
your shiny app
you could place them in different our
markdown chunks
um and also like specify the output
format and
and uh customize to your heart's content
so just to give you like a sense of what
you can do with this sort of thing here
is basically the same data but a better
interface where i can go in
and select different r packages and
compare them
in the same visualization i can choose
different
transformations to the data and then
finally click a download
report to get that rmd source and
the output or like the rendered output
of that rmd source
so and now that we've sort of enabled
our user to interact with a shiny app
find something that they're interested
in
and get a permanent artifact generated
by the shiny app
in some sense what we can do is have
like fully programmable
programmable dynamic reports without
any programming necessary so
here what i've done this is especially
interesting if you work with dynamically
updating data
i can go into my shiny app like find the
packages that i'm interested in
and then i could use something like our
studio connect to schedule this thing to
run
say every day or every month or every
year and then i have like a historical
permanent artifact
give you another sense of what's
possible here here is
a shiny app where i can upload some data
and run an anova analysis on that data
so i've uploaded a data set choosing
like a response and some predictor
variables
checking that the assumptions of my
anova analysis are are okay
that i can actually run this analysis
choose some different predictor
variables actually run the model
get my results of the
test statistics and then finally at the
end of the day
download a report with both the source
and the output that i see in the
application that's all
driven by the data that i've uploaded
and the inputs that i've chosen
in the shiny app all right so in summary
uh interactivity is great but whenever
we do this we're kind of
sort of it comes at the cost of
reproducibility but with shiny meta
you can with some effort at least allow
your users to get some reproducible code
back out of that interactive application
and to add integration to your shiny app
you want to identify
and capture the domain logic use this
dot dot operator to mark reactive reads
and then expand chain to get the code
back
out of the outputs that you're
interested in in the shiny app
and then optionally to distribute that
code to users
you can provide it as a zip bundle with
the rmd source
and results via this build rmd bundle
so thanks
we just have time for a couple quick
questions um how does the use of shiny
meta affect performance since it seems
to be doing a lot of extra evaluation
um so it really
shouldn't affect the performance at all
really
um in the sense that there's two modes
of execution in shiny meta
so when you call expand chain it sort of
opts into this meta execution mode
and that's when that happens it's doing
some computation
to generate code but it's actually you
know
not necessarily evaluating expensive
code
and that evaluation is actually totally
separate from the normal execution mode
that is normally the normal execution is
what allows
like the the output of the time series
to actually be generated in the shiny
app
that's a totally separate execution
model from the generation of the code
i think that's all we have time for
questions um thanks a lot carson thank
you everybody for coming and uh
very bright
you